what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Saki on we are
sitting down with needs Aaron what's up
brother Larry what's up what's up what's
up I'm good
thanks for good yeah yeah this is crazy
I'm happy to be here
I'm gonna flip over the 15 minute timer
that's gonna do two of these suckers
we're gonna talk I'm happy that you're
that you're on the show this is good
let's talk for sure you're 17 yeah
you're in high school here in the city
yes San Francisco yeah and you found
that you care a lot about trying to
inspire people through music yeah yeah
yeah I would say that just rap and all
that yeah and so like Nate goes by MC
high that's yeah MC hi follow on
instagram yeah Instagram SoundCloud
YouTube all that stuff so yeah go check
out check out some of music so so you
know this is really interesting because
you you and I have been sitting around
and talking for a little while with our
boy Charlie yeah shoutout to Charlie's
coming back in the bag in the background
that cuts cuts in the cuts yeah I doing
cuts in the cut so you know Charlie's
also in school do you know Charlie's
like a math whiz engineering etc right
you found this path of like art music
yeah so you know different kids are
finding different paths right now you
know what I found really interesting you
know let's as we get into music we'll
talk we'll get into that I thought what
was really crazy was that you know I'm
25 you guys are 17 but you're already
starting to use language that I don't
understand
yeah what was that mania mania mainly
it's like it's like crazy but with
mayhem named crazies meaning yeah yeah
maybe like language and slang would come
off so fast like yeah it's mainly in
this studio with the YouTube show I
don't know and then what was the other
one you guys were using earlier slide
yes slide I mean oh that means that's
like a load thing though that's like an
old thing like slide give me multiple
different things but in the context that
we're using it like I've heard my my
grandma say slide before like I'm gonna
slide through a slide through like I
it's like the same thing okay but later
yeah what are the kids see so the
Facebook generations over right you guys
really I don't I don't even have a
Facebook
Charlie Facebook no any of the any of
the fellow girls and boys at the school
do any of them probably roughly there's
probably a couple we like one there's
probably a couple now it's more than
what people are Facebook's because on
Instagram if you're trying to do like
professional Instagram account you have
to register through Facebook to get a
business account
oh yeah interesting so I do have a
Facebook but it's a farce yeah exactly
just to get a business account yeah all
right so now so this is the Instagram or
snapchat this Instagram snapchat wave
for sure but is it is it both at the
same time where isn't one or the other
I think Instagram snapchat probably
harder than Instagram right now but
Instagram is definitely better for
content creators and people trying to
like monetize a passion you know like
yeah like this like an entire generation
influenced by entrepreneurship and stuff
like that so with people just trying to
post like their videos or whatever hang
out with the friends snapchats probably
a better place but Instagram also has
the story functions which is good for
like promotion and letting people know
about stuff I'm sure doesn't have a
story function snapchat bez up the story
function my Instagram also has a story
function here correct yeah so like snap
so it's more like friend to friend it's
again has more like promotion to other
yeah
yeah okay mainly mainly like talking to
friends and talking to girls on snapchat
that's the only uses here all right so
that's what's up so okay so now that's
the two main social platforms know our
kids are you still use Twitter but I
don't use Twitter Twitter sucks not well
so we're talking 17 year-olds you guys
would make Twitter accounts and use
Twitter so yeah people used to I I don't
use Twitter just because I have it you
have to invest a lot of time to build up
a certain amount of moments about social
media and I want to focus on two to four
social medias instead of expanding and
getting a Facebook and a tumblr and a
Twitter and you know it's a lot yeah
that's a lot okay so you guys using
musically musically
was that a face I was I was never I
never went through that phase thankfully
I was I was off doing my own thing
trying to I don't know I just wasn't I
would just never got into that but
there's a lot of very crazy people of
music musically yeah alright so so okay
so now as kids are you know do you guys
do you guys in high school or you guys
all like talking about what you want to
do after high school cuz you know we
usually didn't talk about that that much
right so is that kind of still at face
do people do kids in high school kind of
know about what's like what like what
happens like with taxes or with jobs or
with I think saving money or like trying
to make an impact like this out
it's a pens in my conversations I bring
that up a lot cuz that's something I
worry about it's something I care about
and it's like a really present theme in
my music if you listen to a lot of my
music I talk about my future after high
school yeah the reality of a lot of
people's living situations and how some
stuff isn't necessarily set up for you
to prosper and do what you want you know
it's not really set up for you to win
like what what's negative to win make
it's a lot harder to go and make a
business and like oh I want to do a
youtube show for instance it's a lot
harder to do that instead of sign
signing up and working at Safeway you
know totally and that's a free there's
instant gratification you know because
when you're doing something like this
you don't you might be able to see it
see your vision but you're not seeing
your return on investment
like quick you know you're not seeing it
so a lot of people are very scared of
taking the leap and doing well I guess
what we're doing and not having a plan B
because if you haven't plan B it
discharged from the plan a so so I like
how you described it as an instant
gratification from working for someone
or doing something else because you're
working per hour and you're making money
per hour versus when you're doing
something that has a long-term vision
there's not these instant feedback loops
that give you reward okay so you trap
about this in your music and about
having a vision now what is that
vision for you after high school after
high school during high school is the
years where I can really think a lot and
I don't just have to do because right
when I graduate high school the
pressures on you know my own I'm my own
person and I have to make money to live
and I have to you know continue doing
music and following my passion alright
during high school
if I find a plan and get a ground plan
down it's a lot easier to pursue that
once I leave high school because I will
have a lot more time when I'm not in
school yeah we made a plan look like the
plan for me looks like growing in
Instagram following and growing
influence on different platforms for
sure and just releasing more music yeah
and I have it I have it in my head I
can't give away free game you know I
have to keep it up here sometimes I
can't give away free game go back away
free game yeah that's free game free
game for you hate but it's like the
secrets that's the secrets I think it's
not necessarily like a real coveted
secret but if I give away my plan to
succeed in my life people are it's like
increasing competition for you yeah I
don't I don't need to do that to myself
you know it's just like playing myself
to put it out there but it's not like I
know anything more than anybody else
does I just have invested a lot of a lot
more time into thinking about it and
doing a research about it so I sort of
have path cut out on what I need to do I
have a lot of people that are around me
that have the same mindset I'm in a
collective called legacy actually it's a
collective of rappers and managers and
video makers and stuff like that
videographers and there's some members
in New York and a member here so we just
we all have that same mindset
I'm just progressing and being really
strategic and vigilant with the people
that are around us and where we're
trying to go like point A to point B and
just really you're trying to make things
when you're 17 and not just consume
things exactly a lot of people just sit
here and do nothing like sometimes I
catch myself on YouTube and
watch youtube videos just all day and
I'll never get anything done
and that's something that I see a lot of
people doing but they're not like
calling themselves out on it like you're
just like sitting on your ass the entire
day you know right is that do you think
that's what separates the creators from
the consumers especially right now in
like 14 to 18 year-olds is there as
there seem to be a pretty big
distinction like what separates people
in high school that are executing versus
consuming the executors and the
consumers that's really interesting I
actually haven't thought about that but
might my take on it is that that does
that does definitely differentiate the
types of people that are willing to go
out and get it and I know a lot of
people who have dreams and aspirations
to do something and do something that
isn't necessarily like in the cookie
cutter norm of what they're supposed to
do but they don't have the tenacity to
go out and actually do it even though
the tools are right in front of them
yeah so that definitely sometimes people
just don't know where to start right
there did they get worried that oh I'm
gonna start with something and I might
not love it forever and then well that's
why you got to go try it fall on your
face a bunch try number two try number
three figure things out and then
whatever you end up liking going and
pursuing it in a lot more strength and
like you said I was lucky that I found
something that makes me really happy
yeah so young yeah lots of people make
people I talk to I always bring up the
same conversation that we're having like
your goals and aspirations and stuff
like that to people when I meet them for
the first time when I right away like
almost right away because a lot of
people just like oh nice to meet you the
weather's good you know like you go deep
right away I go deep what's a diverse
deep question you like my first deep
question is like do you have goals and
aspirations where you want to be like
yes oh good if you have a passion do you
know what you're gonna do after high
school stuff like that yeah I bring that
up almost right away here depends on the
person but usually I bring that up you
know
it's really interesting what what have
been some of the best answers to their
goals and aspirations from other people
yeah most of the time they say I
idea I'm in high school and I was I mean
75% of the time 80% of the time okay
yeah seventy-five eighty yeah
yeah the most interesting answer that
I've gotten so far is I met this guy and
he's older maybe like 30 or so and I was
talking to him about if he has any goals
I had any goals before he started
working and that sort of trapped into
this job in situation that he can't
really leave because if he does he
doesn't have money to fall back on and
all that stuff like that and I asked him
if he had any dreams and stuff and he
just said no I just imagined myself
working like as a young kid I just
imagined myself just growing up and some
people don't have that calling inside
them that higher purpose that drives
them to like do something that effect do
something that doesn't even affect the
world it just you can't feel content
with yourself if you don't chase it you
know there's like definitely a bigger
purpose in higher you there's almost
stuff in the shower
yeah let's crack in so alright so this
meaning or purpose for so many kids
isn't there what is the missing piece in
the education system for parents or or
for school systems what's the missing
piece that would help kids find their
purpose at younger ages
so that way 80% of the answers aren't I
don't know now you're meant to say that
to me and I'm about to say I don't know
to that I don't know question but I
think there's a lot of stuff that you do
learn in school that isn't necessarily
necessary or it's maybe taking away from
what you do need to learn lots of people
I don't think they're teaching you the
right stuff all the time you definitely
could be focused more on your may if you
have an interest or something you can
definitely focus more on that and
there's maybe under-representation like
all the history books are white you know
late and lots of teachers lots of
teachers away in lots of public schools
and I think there's not enough diversity
in the public school system
I think the public school system is
segregated so lots of people don't get
to have a full experience of life and I
think that costs a lot of problems for a
lot of people of different backgrounds
what is taught in school that is
unnecessary and they want of the math to
be honest like math is very good you
ever Charlie might disagree right
no charlie well the thing is Charlie
wants to go into a math field right
engineering is not feeling more about if
you want to pursue math go for it and
there is a point where sure if you just
drop math you'll be undereducated and
all that stuff but after a point there's
lots of stuff like trigonometry and all
that stuff you're not gonna need to know
how to do it you know like I don't I
don't even know what trigonometry is to
be honest but I was learning today in
school still don't know what it is you
know okay so so math potentially should
end around what geometry maybe maybe but
geometry algebra calculus I mean it just
upended statistics statistics seems kind
of important right well I can see that I
can see statistics being good it just
depends on where you're trying to go
with your life you know like there's
lots of stuff in history that doesn't
need to be basically across all subjects
there's extra meat that they put on it
and it's not even meat it's like it's
like stuff on the outside and there's
extra stuff on the outside and they can
just clear away and maybe more
individualized learning plans for a lot
of kids like I'm dyslexia and dysgraphia
so for me school has always been really
hard like I when I write my raps like I
read them down on the paper or in the
notebook sometimes I write them in my
phone if I'm late you know if I'm trying
to like be faster if I'm on the go but I
never read my raps when I recited back I
memorized the patterns that I wrote the
words like the indentations and the
enters and stuff so maybe if I learn how
to read better that would be better or
maybe it's just my dyslexia I can't read
fast enough to keep up with rapping but
something that people
I feel like those people can under
appreciate different kids strengths and
weaknesses you know today and the to
tailor the educational system towards
different strengths and weaknesses it is
a process of that's gonna take a while
to figure out how to do theirs you oh
that's fine can I explain this real
quick yeah yeah why is that okay so this
is why it's a logo it's actually all
black on the background but if you guys
imagine that this is is white it's like
um right here is the H and right here is
I so it's capital letters aha you better
you have when you put it together it
makes this this symbol yeah I see it
yeah yeah this is sort of a bad like
picture of it but you know people I see
people tag it do the the box it looks
like a windowpane you know yeah correct
yeah so nice it's a bit middle okay so
okay obviously personalized education is
something that like if a kid only needs
to learn maybe tell Algebra one health
or geometry let's say maybe a little bit
of stat so they understand some
statistics stuff there but then if
you're going to engineer and keep
learning math if you're not yeah then
what are you interested in are you
interested in art or a great a lot of
kids don't know what they want to do
though and that's the problem that's
what I can't answer
okay so then what should the surface
level be of like history you know there
should be a certain certain bits of
history that are taught and then
anything else the further depths have to
be unpacked by people if they want to go
that deep so the same thing applies the
science of what should those little bits
be so I know you don't have the answers
to all of this bit I like poking and
prodding this is the youth to figure
this stuff out because I think it's
crazy that 80% of kids in high school
don't really know what they want to do
and that's your sample size and I'm sure
that you know Charlie would you say it's
about 80% of kids in high school don't
know what they want to do
procrastination that's because you got
you have a whole day that you can just
chill and watch YouTube that's facts
like I used to procrastinate so much and
I had to just let lots of people are
procrastinators you know that's that's
what's crazy about it I realized that
there's sort of unappealing layers to
everything I think I used this in a song
but my name is Nate Wright I'm a
procrastinator it's an eight and it's
fascinating you know and taking like
taking the different parties like you
peel peel away layers and once that came
in my mind I was like man I'm really
just sitting here like not doing
anything
looking at beats on YouTube but I'm not
writing anything and stuff like that
yeah
and I just like this handle to get more
motivated and I'll catch myself drifting
off and watching going on tangents but I
feel like every single day my work ethic
is getting stronger which is good and oh
yeah yeah that's good that's good here
because you know that your time is
ticking definitely yeah that's the
scariest part is that like I only have
one more year you know in high school oh
and that's great and then you're thrown
to the Wolves of the economic really
basically and you're trying to knocked
it shoe now chewed up and spit out
you're trying to succeed in that Konami
machine I couldn't even imagine myself
working at a job for like my life you
know but that's why that's what my
vision is good for you that means you
know you're an entrepreneur my friend I
was with my friend the other day and he
said he said that for everybody who's
ever met he can see like where that they
could be in their future and for me he
just sees just like fogginess you know
he just doesn't see anything and I was
just like wow that's crazy you can't see
if I'm heading the wrong or right
direction he's telling me like it's not
a bad or a good thing I just can't see
where you going and that's my friend
that's actually shot by stick he shoes
my music videos and say yeah that's my
boy
but I like how you've found something
you've lost on to it you're now building
it you have a strategic plan some secret
sauces that you're not some super
sausage which is good you got a music
video coming out
right yeah tell us about the music video
what are you talking about in it and the
music video you see I don't I don't know
if this is gonna be out by the time it
drops her if that's after but he'll be
out of the wreck we put the link in the
bar for the for the for the record the
music video is called 400 nights and
basically in the song I'm talking about
why 400 nights yeah okay yeah I'm gonna
get into that but the song is about my
experience in Colorado when I was like
13 ish to 13 from 13 14 15 I was in
Colorado at a residential treatment
center actually because I was going
through a lot of things and I definitely
was not the person I was like I could a
couple years ago they let me drop we're
good why we get alright yeah I
definitely did a lot of improving on
myself and like you know a lot of stuff
like that but I'll get I'll get into
that story of how that came to be like
definitely through my career that's
definitely gonna be like it told a big
part of it that's only a couple years
ago for you right three years ago like I
met charlie like I was visiting the
school like shadowing yeah and I met
charlie like when I was still at that
place and then I went back I came back
got this back surgery right because I
like scoliosis or whatever and my grade
was gonna pop off and puncture my lunch
so I have like a big scar down to my
back and I have two rods and screws and
a heavy vertebrae oh wow yeah a lot of
people don't even know that looking at
me but on my back I'm not gonna get up
and turn around but on my back there's a
big scar and I always have a great
posture because I can't then bend my
back you know but yet like Charlie
probably remembers I was so crippled at
the beginning of year I could not walk
or run like we would have to that walk
hell is slow and stuff you know and now
you're running there now I'm running in
those sports and stuff before it's -
yeah good but um so that was like the
big journey like that's like
two-and-a-half years of nothing just
being blocked out from society because
I'm blocked out in Colorado not being
locked in this box basically
you know and then I'm out and I'm in my
room laying down for months and months
and months and months and that's what
inspired me to start really working at
it was that depression anxiety what was
a somewhat what was the locked up in the
room yeah I think it was a mix of all
those things and didn't have to do with
like family or like what was the big
thing I think I think that mix of
everything friends really friends here
yeah mix of everything I think it's a
mix of everything I was going through
and I was younger how many kids in your
high school have some sort of like
depression or anxiety depression is one
I'm just said yeah depressions
walky in my boy joaquin garcia in legacy
said that everybody is depressed in
America that's a quotable quote yeah
everybody's depressed in America America
makes people depressed maybe well the
the economic machine that's pumping out
some of the greatest innovations in the
world is also driving people up the wall
because they're all kind of climb and
fight and make this impact and it's it
so it can be a little messy so it's four
hundred nights because because I was
locked up for four yeah I was in there
for 400 nights yeah and I talked about
the hook I talked about Sylar which is
the mixtape I'm about to drop talk about
Mike
there's you gotta listen yeah I show you
a clip of it yeah that's me and then I
like the video itself so nice - so it'll
be good that's is a first music video
let's say it's the first official music
video because I did a couple of videos
with different songs but they weren't to
the full extent of what I'm trying to
portray in my music you know there were
definitely just me trying to like figure
out who I am and what my musics gonna
sound like in my image and you know
sonically everything so like when you
start rapping unless you have it already
set up you're gonna spend at least six
months to a year figuring out who you're
trying to be as a rapper and as a person
basically because I'm trying to be
pretty transparent so Who I am in my
music I feel like I should give you a
beat and then you should freestyle and
right now I can we do that a bit I'll
give you beat a centering yeah - Papa -
Papa the best marketing strategy of all
time he died I had the second best
marketing strategy of all time I'm gonna
stay a lot I'm not concerned return on
investment being content to shoot down
stress but I got a 10 page essay check
this and I get back get a check in pen
and let me wait all right lemme monetize
especially now I'm going to like write
me but I can find anything I like more
than a vision now I'm gonna want to send
a minute camp attend be ready to live on
my own steady money won't make me happy
in the [ __ ] that I bought with it will
hey dude that was way too fast
I don't like Robbie fast at all but that
was the that was the pocket I had to hop
in there but yeah yeah give me give me a
beat let me see what I can do all right
I like this I like a speed okay we're on
YouTube live simulation lab we're coming
at you hive the hive minds what's inside
the hive mind your own or mine now
neurons are thought you're a ring right
up in thy skull with me now come and
dance with me as we build up the treants
Boal is Asian science inside Sciences my
rhyme I love it
hi just like it's fun to mess around you
know you and I were talking about that a
bit like we just let go with flow and
like yeah I've been practicing it over
and over again as a young person so now
you're wiring yourself up to be ready
for this yeah definitely and and just
even as someone that's like a little
older than you I think it's also
important to just like for people closer
like 25 really 20 30 all these different
ages like how can people that are close
like 20-30 how can they feel free to
flow openly they're not have to be just
in their life in their life pattern or
with freestyling in your life pattern
yeah that's crazy I think I was watching
this documentary about flow and there
was this guy who worked at a burger
joint or whatever and he would flip
these burgers and was talking about how
he had this flow and he would had these
launch of patties and he would be
flipping him like this doing some crazy
like little stuff and I don't know he
had like a really cool thing that was
just floating yes Pat and I think it
makes you happier to like do that listen
and then there's someone that flows by
working as a checker at Safeway
definitely that's some people some
people can feel content with doing that
you know and I commend people that can
you know because no matter what you do
if you feel happy with yourself that's
all that really matters because people
always are talking about you achieve big
things being entrepreneur but that's
where I think a lot of the depression
comes from yeah not be not feeling
fulfilled if you feel happy with what
you're doing
if you feel fulfilled but truly feel
fulfilled not fake fulfilling yeah like
if you that's all that really matters
you know interesting so if the
fulfillment is all that really matters
then ignorant can be bliss yes
actually but is that actually is that
actually good world if everyone's just
taking the blue Co all the time it's not
if everybody though it's only okay cuz
we don't even know about all these
alternate realities and all that I don't
want to get in that crazy [ __ ] right now
well we got it
do a look we got to do a little bit yeah
all right if everybody if everybody is
in their own own dimension and own like
space and mindset you know like you know
you don't know if it matters you know
what you're thinking or what I'm
thinking or what anybody else is
thinking
Matthieu if if I'm ignorant to a lot of
things that you're not then and I'm
happy that's all that matters you know
as long as I'm not negatively affecting
people around you if it works so so
ignorance is bliss until it causes other
people negativity or suffering really
hillier yeah but I think even we can
take an even easier yeah so let's say
you're happy being a checker at Safeway
yeah and then let's say that you come
home and you're having a conversation
with your spouse or brother whoever and
the conversation becomes something about
some sort of a fact something that that
is true right and maybe you just didn't
know that it was true but you just kept
saying that it was true even though it
was false
so you're ignorant is actually causing
more chaos hmm
can you rephrase it yeah so like for
example if maybe maybe you didn't know
that the embassy got moved to Jerusalem
the US Embassy right then so let's see
you didn't know that and so but you were
arguing saying that it's in Tel Aviv's
though yeah right then you just kept
argue every way then that's that's when
ignorance starts affecting other people
and o- yeah so that's when it stops
that's a threshold yeah okay so you can
be happy as with ignorance as long as
you're happy that's it that's what's
important breath and as soon as it
starts affecting negativity or suffering
on other people I think if you have a
lot of these conversations with your
friends
I took me and try to talk about this
sort of stuff but not not as much of a
layer yeah there's a lot of very
ignorant should we talk about too but
not as much of a layer that we're going
into but like I have a lot of friends
that I talk about like very like
important things with this is not a new
conversation yeah yeah yeah yeah and I'm
and I'm curious how many people your age
are talking about things like this I
think a lot of people think about these
sort of things just don't talk about it
cuz it's not as socially acceptable to
be like well talking about all this
crazy stuff let's make it socially
acceptable all right how about our AMC
highlights here let's let's hear your
vision for like three five years out
like what do you what do you what do you
want to be doing who do you want to be
impacting how are you gonna be doing it
three to five years out all right let's
see if three to five years I'll be out
of high school
I'm still seven I'll just turned 17 okay
let's see
I want to be an influencer I'm
completely fine not being famous not
being on the radio and not being like
super popular I just want to have my
influence in my circle you know like
like I'm relevant to the people that my
subject matter is relevant to you know
so I'm definitely gonna have impact
before anything happens before I spread
out and you have my city behind me so I
need I need to definitely grow in the
bay before anything else but I just see
myself doing what I'm doing now just on
a bigger and more extreme platform I'm
not working with people collaborations
with people getting better marketing
probably cuz market market is the key
this is this is the game this is your
game I'm gonna put people on a lot of
people already know this so if you know
this then big up to you you know but
people gonna have trash music
marketing's all that matters you know
ease that's so bad that's so fast so bad
so trash I know it's the worst so that
kind of reminds me about the ignorance
is bliss thing it can be the worst
content if it has good marketing people
will pick it up and has to be
professional content like professionally
produced a mix or if it's YouTube video
professionally a lit but it can be like
like sexy prank gone wrong
bubble wrap any anything you know like
you just need to have good marketing
okay let's take back just a couple steps
to one you said that you want to be an
influencer with the people that care
about what you're making and what you're
producing and then people that is
relevant that you're that you're
relevant to and that are relevant to you
and so that's fulfillment for you that's
you're happy yeah I'm already I'm gonna
be honest I'm already pretty fulfilled
because I'm feeling fulfilled right now
sometimes obviously I'm still hungry too
I'm super super hungry to do music and
good for you like work and get my stuff
out there but oh look at that that's my
youtube yeah I don't I don't have any
music videos up right now uh you
probably run away probably that's a good
song
in the middle in the middle we had my
YouTube video actually here go to Hue go
to my soundcloud yeah let's go to the
song go to the south clap pause that
because the my YouTube is under
construction has that go to the south
which soundcloud.com /mc su hai for her
high for 400 and that's probably the
wrong MC huh yeah there we go
I'll put slowed down the first one I do
like this one yeah this one's good I had
my brother Jian it yeah he's from the
bay I was here this one yeah definitely
go and follow on Soundcloud yeah that's
the key that's the key speak about I get
to rather be a better yo your mental
state will be affected immediately when
you follow me on cell phone you'll be a
better person by telling following on
cell phone
that's how it works so and that's one of
your goals that's that's right that's
how you want to be fulfilled that's I
would be fulfilled
negative as I am right now for
everything that I do and make yeah yeah
and I know that's gonna happen it very
soon in the very same future that's
gonna happen so right now no one comes
from a thousand people checking up
that's just for now though I'm like
that's that's the steps in the next
couple of months I'm talking about in
years and years I want to be
upper-middle class making rap music you
know cool
that's that's it that's hard that's a
bit that's all right so that's our
thirty minutes so we'll have I'll end it
on the song well yeah well Shawn's
rolling in the back yeah slow Don's
rolling right now oh is it
yeah bill Reilly what does that mean
take me out come on we'll do it live
so we'll go we'll go out with with the
song and we'll ask you a couple
questions on the way out really thinks
the most beautiful thing in the world
they're probably my future girlfriend
that's gonna be the most beautiful thing
in the world
yeah you know it charlie know it yeah
thanks know my family is the most
beautiful thing in the world my mom my
dad my grandma my stepdad my sister
everybody in my family is the most
beautiful thing in the world and my
brothers are the most beautiful thing in
the world like my brothers and legacy
charlie shot by stick and yeah all my
all my brothers you know that's good
most beautiful thing in the world and
then do you think that were alone in the
cosmos
no what do you think I am no definitely
not what do you what do you think other
life is like in the cosmos that you say
me you think they're like humans then I
mean you're probably alien you're pretty
good guy yeah yeah not no other life in
the cosmos
there's definitely other life in the
cosmos maybe maybe I'm not from this
planet you know play play off that
thought more late uh but back when I was
talking about like how everybody could
be there in their own reality
how are you an alien yeah uh yeah I
don't know I don't know anything you
know nobody really knows anything I
could be an alien who's probably not but
I could be I'm maybe I'm too normally
being it
that shit's a secret in anyway even if
he wasn't yeah even if I wasn't a lien
kid I probably wouldn't tell you right
how about you know who is who is an
alien hmm Beyonce she's an alien
honey jay-z's man how do you know the
really there are lizards however they
we're gonna end on that nice it's
conspiracy [ __ ] I'm just kidding
what's your favorite conspiracy theory
my favorite conspiracy theory hmm that's
probably hard probably like probably
like son denial I like what a son denial
like people think of this like a dome
over you and that like everything's
artificial everything yeah no it's real
Oh actually um we heard it in you in
your music and what a Truman Show Oh
word The Truman Show because yeah living
in the snow globe feeling like The
Truman Show when I was in Colorado
it's like a snow globe you know and I
felt like the only real person I felt
sort of alienated so maybe I'm an alien
cuz I feel alienated that's also
solipsism there's a whole school lot for
that meaning you Kim what is autism you
can't believe anything outside of what
you're perceiving yeah it'd be true to
be existing that's how I felt at that
time so yeah I was living in a friend
now your friends yeah my friends and
family that you lovely people they
believe are real yeah yeah yeah do you
think we're in a computer simulation
damn I also I also heard that one I have
some friends that were talking to me
about that one um I don't know if we're
in a computer simulation but in like 200
300
not 400 years because everything's 400
we're gonna probably be in a computer
simulation
go to 2418 marking it down in my
calendar you know what's crazy
one of my favorite rappers Capital steez
number 47
I was I was born on April 47th so in
2047 I'll be 47 that's pretty crazy
April 47 not well maybe April 47th is a
thing I don't know not April 7th so it's
like so except yeah don't force them
yeah yeah that's pretty crazy I can't
believe you guys are Jen's ears its own
crazy the frenzy
jug's ears kids are being born today
that are zero in this 2018 it's just
nuts that's power your language is so
crazy I mean we're talking pretty much
the same but you guys are dropping like
you know we're topping Maggie
Maggie's babies yeah we talk like a
normal and [ __ ] I saw you guys tossing
around the ball you mean you guys have
energy you're still throwing around the
ball back and forth like we used to do
that too so I mean there's still a lot
of similarities but thrown around mr.
buck over his head just like Ron isn't
an interesting that how time goes by and
how things change and how you look down
at the younger generations and no it's
not it's not interested that's that's
what love is boring at all you see life
is boring as hell after a while you just
get used to it
yeah what's your old and salty like Ron
it's your own salty leg around no
meaning anymore
it's like taking me away I'm ready for
death that's no wrong Ron's got a good
amount of good spirit in him he's still
hustling hard which is very impressive
51 year old you like have it going here
like you guys are this studio you guys
obviously can't see through the camera
and stuff but this studio is crazy like
you guys invested in the camera and
making your money back really like on
all points of the access doing different
grinds to make your money back you know
like it's not like you're just doing one
thing making YouTube videos there's
multiple different aspects and different
like
things that you run out of this little
place you know yeah it's like crazy I I
walked in here I was very impressed on
like what you guys have going on like I
hope to be in a position like this when
I'm older that's for sure
thanks brother with that attitude with
this mentality that you have now of like
envisioning your future and setting
yourself goals short-term goals to get
there and you will and then you have an
obligation to help other people get to
that point as well
yeah not everyone's gonna walk through
the door right but you can show them the
door you can help I didn't I didn't walk
the door you know like like those are
walking through I'm what I am walking
through yeah yeah yeah I haven't even
watched the door yet yeah neither am i
you know but i don't think anyone does
in their whole life maybe maybe five
happens after maybe I walk through a
couple doors who knows yeah yeah all
right this is good conversation that's
been a lot of fun I'm seeing tonight can
I hit it on one thing yeah but I think
when you die you just see what's that
guy's name the guy that plays God in
every movie Morgan's Mel Gibson Morgan
Freeman when you die you just see Morgan
Freeman's face being like come here son
just like taking you that's what
happened that's what happens when you
die I swear that's that one's you know
that's why you're an alien you were in
done it that's why you know oh maybe a
hundred percent 100 percent yeah this
isn't what this this isn't my first life
you know I was a sailor in my past later
your sailor that's when the album's
called sailor yeah the mixtape mix it
the album's gonna be crazy you can't
talk about that yet all right yeah so
calm for slush don't see hi 400 oh thank
you wrong yes right should be better now
soundcloud.com
/mc hi 400 links in the bio go check it
out yeah own ACO supporters music give
them a follow give them a follow on
Instagram as well
I'm see hi 400 now emcee hi I'm just go
for it emcee hi underscore for on the
intense thi and then let's let's build a
let's build a bright future for young
people definitely to do it like young
people that are in high school right now
what is up with this depression and this
and people not having purpose like same
thing was going on in my day but same
thing was going on ron's but that's an
it's a change like it's been happening
forever it's but it's gotten worse in
some cases they have more access to
technology but that's also created the
whole social media crap let's do it
right now subscribe to the channel join
us in the simulation families and have
fun time thanks for coming much love
this paper fun subscribe join comment
below we'd love for you to join we got a
patreon action if you want to join help
a sports studio yeah we'll be back with
some more dope young minds as well in
the future and peace out much love
everyone yep yeah
[Music]
freedom and chill calling by ready pal
warm sweater let it be Nelson Mandela
tell me you're better in like a nexus
effect sections on who is better but I'm
only getting a youthful Takanawa get it
like listening visit with that chivalry
reporting using presumed [ __ ] news
junkies some no beach to freeze so
mentally probably never be so volatile
be addressed to me
Phil I see cloud fishes need more water
see ya
the anatomies shuttles for the birds we
got paying for this funny thing is the
more meth on the streets of week putting
fingers compared to people I'm living
the tree pain in my heart
[Music]
[ __ ] ain't real did get you killed do
a Carlucci own paperwork that that
[ __ ] quill and I can't make no money
when those snake [ __ ] spin up a now
board with the blinds and the Apes [ __ ]
stop pocket watch it and worry about
your plate [ __ ] rest in peace my family
might be it happens gangster so much
never finish streets I feel it coming
from II wasn't gonna play not such a
bang-up it just coming from me coming
ain't no love in here put some chains on
this here I want romance
Corden I sleep on plastic for the CEO
thinking on the ferryboat I just love
living in the snow glow feeling like
Truman Show sinking on the ferryboat you
called nicely from plastic for to see
you're thinking on the ferryboat I just
love living in the snow glow feeling
like the Truman Show thinking run the
ferryboat
[Music]